دقائق قبل ساعه الحاديه عشر وكل لحظه
مدروسه وتم يعني اجراء تدريب عليها عده
مرات خاصه خلال الايام القليله الاخيره
الاحتفالات او المراسم بالاحرى داخل دروس
من سته تستمر لمده ساعتين وهناك عده مراحل
واجزاء مختلفه لحفل التتويج نفسه والتوت
التي تعود الى الف
عام الكثيرا فعليا خلال الالف سنه الماضيه
هذا هو طبعا مقر التتويج كل ملوك المملكه
المتحده علما انه الملك سعود هو الملك رقم
بالنسبه للمملكه المتحده وكلهم تم تتويجهم
في هذا المكان في نفس هذا الكرسي ايضا
الذي سيجلس عليه كرسي الملك
يعود الى عام 1066 يعني عمر هذا الكرسي
700 سنه
والتاج طبعا الذي سيرتديه في لحظه التتويج
ايضا تاج القديس ادوارد وزنه تقريبا 2 كلغ
يحتوي على 400 من المجوهرات المختلفه
والاحجار الكريمه
بتكلفه تقريبا نصف مليون دولار امريكي بعد
كل هذه الفعاليات داخل مصر هناك موكب شان
سيتحول من دير ويسمنتر مره ثانيه في
الاتجاه العكسي الى قصر باقيه ولكن هذه
المره سيقل الملك وقرينه في
الذهبيه البوظه كما جرت العاده في كل
حفلات التتويج السابقه
وتتوجهان الى الحدائق
لتلقي التحيه العسكريه سيتم ايضا اطلاق
الدقات البندق او الطلقات البندقيه
وسيتواجهان الى شرفه قصر لمتابعه استعراض
جوي يشمل 60 طائرات عسكريه فالعديد من
الاحتفالات التي ننتظرها تمتد على مدار
الساعات القادمه
كارينا من الامور التي تمت اثارتها يعني
بالايام وبالاسابيع الماضيه هو هل الملك
تشارلز حارس العقيده ام حامل لكل
المعتقدات طبعا وفقا يعني
للدستور والقانون هناك هو حارس للعقيده
لماذا
يعني كيف يمكن ربطه مع ما ستضمنه مراسم
التتويج لطقوس ومشاركه ممثلين عن مختلف
الاديان خلال
طقوس التتويج يعني هذا الحدث فعليا يقلط
ما بين جوانب عديده من الحياه البريطانيه
التاريخ البريطاني الارسال البريطاني من
ناحيه هو حدث دوله كما نعرف لذا التكلفه
هي تاتي على على الحكومه يعني الحكومه هي
التي تدعم هذه التكاليفه وحدث دوله ولكنه
ايضا حدث عسكري لانه الرئيس او عفوا الملك
تشارلز هو رئيس القوات المسلحه ولكن ايضا
قبل كل ذلك هو ايضا حدث ديني لانه يتم
داخل هذا الدير هذه الكنيسه القائم على كل
هذه الفعاليات هو رئيس
لان طبعا هو رئيس الكنيسه الامريكانيه
كنيسه انجلترا التي طبعا تمتد حول العالم
ليس فقط هنا في المملكه المتحده لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات